hey guys my name is Jess it is the 23rd
well guess and I'm here with the most
exciting things that happened in gaming
today Jay sex mankind divided has a
bunch of microtransactions and while you
can get through the game without them
against the lowdown according to the
listings on the xbox and playstation
stores you're able to spend money on a
number of different things to accelerate
your progress this includes credit parks
which range from one real-world dollar
for 1,000 credits to ten dollars for
15,000 as well as a five dollar assault
pack that comes with a custom skinned
rifle the chaff augmentation and a
number of grenades and ammo you can also
pick up the praxis kit packs which range
from one to seven dollars and can be
used to activate augmentations in the
game there are also a ton of chipset
packs that begin at 10 for one dollar
and go all the way up to 500 for thirty
dollars they use in mankind's divided
breach mode in June producer flow Marty
explained you can play the game without
ever having to spend a dollar I promise
but we will have a few accelerators and
things like putting the odds a bit
better in your favor de sex mankind
divided is also getting a thirty dollar
season pass that comes with multiple
story expansions the next xbox one
backwards compatibility enabled game has
been announced and it's none other than
call of duty to Microsoft Larry herb
announced the news on Twitter today call
of duty two will join club duty black
ops as the second game in the franchise
to be included in the backwards
compatibility roster it's unlikely to be
the last though as five of the six most
requested games for backwards
compatibility support on the Xbox
feedback site are called Judy titles
current legal duty black ops 2 is
leading the pack with over 185 thousand
votes are followed by Skyrim the first
three modern warfare games and finally
world at war the release date for dark
souls series first dlc ashes of
arendelle has been revealed the upcoming
expansion will be available from October
25 a trailer for the dlc was posted on
twitter but linked to a private video
and subsequently deleted suggesting it
was probably
not supposed to be announced just yet
it's a fair guess that we can expect it
to hit the internet again soon in a more
official capacity a previous Dark Souls
3 DLC week suggested the expansion would
contain Maps bosses enemies and
additional weapon and armor sets the two
upcoming expansion packs will be bundled
together in the $25 season pass and the
tweet recently taste that a big
announcement was coming on August 24 so
you don't have long to wait on that one
ped two games left for stories on
titanfall 2 and PlayStation now for pc I
will see you again tomorrow